I constantly cannot verbalize my
thoughts written and vocal regardless of
topic and my level of knowledge tips for
verbalizing thoughts to get them into
writing and therefore speech well what I
would say Lauren is do this like read
something put it aside try to summarize
it in writing and talk while you're
doing it and then write down what you
say and don't edit while you're doing
that see one of the problems that people
have when they're trying to write is
they try to write a good sentence they
they not only try to write a sentence
but they try to write a good sense and
you can't do that you have to write a
sentence that's hard enough and then you
have to edit it so allow yourself to
write badly I'm dead serious about this
like write a bad bad bad first draft and
then edit it if you get rid of 70% of it
so what that's exactly what should
happen so like if you want to write a
thousand word essay you should start by
writing a really bad two thousand word
essay and then you should get rid of the
worst 50% you can do that iteratively I
have a document online it's it's if you
go to my website under courses there's
psychology for thirty is the course I
should make this more public but under
cycle psychology for thirty there's a
template for writing and if you went
looked at that template it tells you it
answers your question I produced this
little guidebook for for writing that
will help and if you write enough you'll
learn to speak the other thing I would
say too is that it might be anxiety
that's doing you might think about
joining a club like Toastmasters or
maybe if you're a university student to
public speaking something where you'd
get in front of people and then when
you're in front of people don't talk to
the group talk to the individuals within
the group and let yourself be bad at it
you'll get better as you practice